I'm so hungry, I could eat
a (bleep) Nissan Versa!
Me too!
No, do not text
Michael, Amy!
No!
I love him and it's
none of your business.
What are these
(bleep) baskets doing?
Who is that guy?
Two roommates, both drunk
and only one chance to win.
The challenge, create an
unforgettable meal using
a basket of mystery
ingredients collected
from your kitchen
before time runs out.
And the losing chef
will be "Sauced."
(screaming)
Chef Amy, Chef Kelsie,
today you have...
A half-eaten Chobani
yogurt from 2012.
Four baby carrots.
A shriveled lime
and a bottle of Lexapro.
Your time starts now.
Go, go, go,
go, go, go!
Go, go, go, go!
No, no, no!
Go, go, go, go, go!
Okay, hurry, hurry,
hurry, hurry...
Okay!
Okay, here we go, okay--
this is it!
Shots, shots,
shots, shots!
Mmmm!
Okay, okay, okay.
Okay, okay, give me
one more!
One more, one more,
one more.
Okay, one more.
One more and then
we do this game.
Give me it.
(Amy)
My name is Amy.
This is bonkers, like, you guys
realize that, right-- Okay.
Wait, am I on
that screen?
Can you move it
so I can see?
Before I
dropped out of UNLV...
Wait.
... I worked at a burrito place
called The Dugout,
so as soon as I saw
the lime, I'm thinking, like...
burrito?
This is (bleep) broken.
(Kelsie)
I work in a bead kiosk.
It's a good gig.
But maybe my thing
is cooking!
Oh, my--
I'm going so fast right now.
And look!
Oh, this is
a tricky basket.
Especially when you're as
blasted as these two chefs are.
More ingredients!
(Mateo)
I like Amy's confidence,
though.
She has all four burners
on high and nothing cooking.
This would never
fly at FUD.
Two minutes, chefs.
Amy...
Look at me,
Amy, Amy.
You were the prettiest girl
at Fiddlesticks tonight.
The bartender was
so into you.
18, 17, 16, 15...
... 14, 13, 12, 11...
... ten, nine,
eight, seven...
... six, five,
four...
... three, two, one...
Time's up,
please step away.
Judges...
Chefs.
Today, I have prepared for
you a bruleed Lexapro,
parsnip coulis,
spring carrots,
and roasted fennel.
Oh, (bleep).
I like the acidity of the
lime with the starchiness
of the Lexapro.
Chef Amy.
What?
Oh-- Chefs.
Today I prepared for
you mayonnaise
from a Myrtle
Beach mug
that Michael gave me.
I think we've made
our decision.
I believe so, yeah.
Whose dish will
be Sauced?
Chef Kelsie.
Congratulations, you are
the "Sauced" champion.
I'm a for-real chef!
That's fair.
That's fair,
you deserve it.
Can you guys get out
of our apartment?
Yeah.